mais non mais c'est surtout la journée
internationale du brésil brasil
[Applaudissements]
bon
alors évidemment voilà vous avez compris
tout de suite samba immédiatement
10 avec toi est ce qu il a fait le geste
de rotation
monaco
attend on va peut-être pouvoir le mettre
vraiment en oeuvre ce geste là mais de
façon un peu plus conséquente d'accord
évidemment on fait pas les choses à
moitié je sais que cheryl est pas là
mais quand même j'ai demandé j'ai
demandé et on m'a accordé des danseuses
brésiliennes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les
gars comme le brésil et le marocain
parce que moi traiter comme ça j'étais
encore vu ça ça n'a rien à voir j'espère
que vous avez bien regardé comment
faisait et opérait ces jeunes femmes ils
dansent merveilleusement bien parce
qu'évidemment ça va être à votre tour de
me lancer
alors qu ignorer vous que oui je ne suis
pas serré la nonna j'ai fait j'ai fait
la demande j'évolue parce que vous avez
envie d'un petit peu de voix là
d'apporter un peu de culture dans
l'émission donc samba signifie nombril
en langue bantoue la langue parlée par
de nombreux esclaves déportés au brésil
à la fin du 19e siècle ah oui on est
donc la danse samba consiste à secouer
son nombril au rythme des percussions
alors c'est pas tout à fait seule
précision ouais c'est nombril et aux
alentours c'est à dire qu'il ya des gars
aussi très bien et très vite et ça veut
dire aussi des êtres animés être agité
être excité d'accord gaye otis yanina
quoi en fait on appelait ça la nonna
d'accord
parce qu'on va faire c'est que c'est
vous qui allez choisir ça c'est toi qui
va choisir wiki qui veux-tu voir danser
la samba autour de la table à écoute ça
me paraît évident avec isabelle
la tuna venu tout seul tu l'as vu
accompagner je l'avais accompagné
accompagné deux et je pense que c'est
l'élégance voudrait que ce soit elle qui
choisit sa très bien d'accord alors
isabelle avec qu'ils soient traités
danser la samba
[Rires]
pas super gouvernement tienne de
sangatte à l'envi pays dont je suis
l'invité
mystère d'ailleurs c'est parce qu'on
devine et puis c'était ou pas regarde
voilà que l'invité mystère alors mais
note une grande malade toi c'est gagner
dans ce bien regarder
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est impossible [ __ ] il a vanté toi
aussi merci voilà we believe the
national comme c'est pas la même barre
il saisit pas les tice à la batucada
c'est ça ouais
d'accord va bien et vous faire mal et
des chaussures
mais
j'ai ça isabelle comme à l'habitude de
bien recevoir les invités mais de là à
leur mettre la culotte devant le meds
voilà a manqué à monter gad est
particulièrement apprécié l'invitation
moi j'ai pas vu ce que vous avez
quelques mois si tu veux j'avais
anticipé quand elle
va se passer
mais on met une bonne date où on dit non
mais je pense que déjà on salue le
courage l'audace et la participation
mais on n'est pas scotché par la
performance c'est ça moi je pose mon bel
danse magnifiquement ont dû brésil tu
vois moi je pense que quand même pour
lever le niveau il y en a 1 autour de la
table qui à mon avis est absolument
exceptionnel mais vraiment exceptionnel
non il fait son grand retour
exceptionnel
pour m6
[Applaudissements]
vautour
vraiment au niveau merci merci
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas c'est pas dingue
danse avec les fans
franchement c'est pas bien mais qui là
encore c'est l'agglo ralenti c'est mieux
même - ouais je suis pas sûr vu un choix
je pense que cette séquence est pourri
on est bien d'accord on est d'accord
d'accord qu'on est sur une séquence
pourri non
ce n'est pas là qu'on dit pas la vérité
voilà on dit les choses comme quand il
est là allez si vous le permettez donc
eu la bonne idée ce serait guillaume
genton granier naturel
[Applaudissements]
j'ai fait les gens moi je suis blessé je
faisais comme sport aujourd'hui j'ai
fait les meubles
au site et aux services flash et je suis
blessé aujourd'hui enchâssée
makala pardon je suis désolé fois c'est
bon ok c'est vrai que si l'invité le
demande dans une émission
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
ce sont les meilleurs
moi franchement ce petit déhanché et en
plus avec moi j'avais le nez sur votre
cul cul vraiment vous avez un petit
coucou qui bouge vous n'êtes pas du tout
objectif c'était une catastrophe et
marisa bon bah on soulève des doutes
étaient pleins de reggae il allie danse
du beurre
descendre il est touchant
regarde là on voit qu'il a souffert
ouais
[Rires]
merci mais là c'est fini jean labib
rennais on arrache le nul
[Applaudissements]